weil der nächste Skandal bei den
Öffentlich-Rechtlichen wie fast immer
geht's ums Geld denn es sind Beträge die
hätte wohl jeder der fleißig arbeitet
geht gerne auf dem Konto
432.000 Euro fürs nichts tun und eine
Rente von 9000 € ja dieses lukrative
Abfindungspaket bekommt rbb
Programmdirektor Jan Schulte Kellinghaus
der vorzeitig sein Sessel räumt das sind
Informationen von unseren Kollegen von
Business Insider ja Normalsterbliche die
können von solchen Summen natürlich nur
träumen sie sind es aber die solche
Abfindungen und Pensionen mit ihrem
Rundfunkbeitrag finanzieren Herr Stahl
finden Sie dass der Rundfunkbeitrag
ihren funkbeitrag trotzdem gut angelegt
ist
garantiert nicht ich meine der Mann hat
sicherlich seine Leistung erbracht aber
steht die Leistung zu dem was wir dafür
bezahlen müssen und vor allen Dingen bei
denen der ganzen Kritik und die ganzen
Skandalen die hier schon beim rbb
gewesen sind ist das glaube ich das
falsche Signal vor allen Dingen wenn ich
immer wieder denke wir sollen den Gürtel
irgendein enger schneiden und dann
gibt's so eine Abfindung ich meine ja
wie heißt immer so die oberen 10.000
davon haben wir 700 und ein paar 30 im
Bundestag die genauso abgehoben sind ich
denke man sollte vielleicht mal
überlegen ob diese Gebühren nicht anders
einzusetzen sind vor allem für auch
Probleme die wir in unserem Land haben
oder ja da müssen ja andere auch private
Sender müssen ja auch sich selbst ihr
Geld herbeizaubern vielleicht sollten
die das auch mal aber
wir werden sehen was die Zukunft bringt
denn das ist definitiv das falsche
Signal und ich als Bürger kann schon
sagen auch über das was ich teilweise da
sehe was der öffentliche Rundfunk zeigt
besonders in den letzten zweieinhalb
Jahren der Pandemie würde ich sagen ich
würde eigentlich schon bald sagen wir
zahlen mal nicht mal gucken was passiert
wegsperren können Sie uns alle nicht
über die Zahlen reden schauen Sie noch
öffentlich-rechtliche
Tradition
Blick in die deutsche Gesellschaft oder
was Sie über sich selber denkt ich
schaue sonst überhaupt nichts anderes
und mehr und mehr erwische ich mich
darüber dass ich eine Tatort eine
Viertelstunde später in der Mediathek
schaue weil es um 20:15 Uhr auch nicht
mehr schaffe also das lineare Fernsehen
könnte für mich auch nicht existieren
ist gerade gesagt gerade die
Pensionslasten die verschlingenden ganz
ordentlichen Batzen jetzt gibt's neues
Projekt bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen
man will Social Media aktiver werden
also so etwas wie Twitter und Facebook
machen ist das denn für sie eine gute
Entwicklung
möchte tatsächlich ein Facebook eine Art
Twitter alternative etablieren das ist
ungefähr so wie wenn Opel versucht einen
Porsche zu bauen also unglaublich was
für eine Anmaßung dass ein Unternehmen
ein Staatsunternehmen in
Anführungszeichen es ist in von der
Struktur her ähnlich tatsächlich in der
Lage sein möchte zu wissen was Ihre
Mitarbeiter bzw ihre Kunden wollen und
das können sie gar nicht weil es fehlt
der Marktpreis es fehlt überhaupt der
Austausch mit den entsprechenden Nutzern
von daher ja ein weiteres Milliardengrab
herzlichen Glückwunsch nur sagen also
ich höre schon in dieser Runde wird kein
gutes Zeugnis ausgestellt Jan wie siehst
du das ganze muss man da so wie
kassenstall das auch angedeutet hat
irgendwann mal wirklich über eine
radikale Reform nachdenken es gibt immer
mehr die sagen brauche ich eigentlich
gar nicht mehr öffentlich-rechtliche
absolut richtig richtig
gesagt haben ja fast behindert zu der
Frage Tatort ein Spiegel der
Gesellschaft genau das ist glaube ich
nämlich nicht abgesehen davon dass da
dauernd jemand ermordet wird aber wenn
wir mal anschauen wie Unternehmer
beispielsweise im Tatort dargestellt
werden dann werden sie zu großen Teilen
immer
negativ dargestellt ist immer der böse
Unternehmer der irgendjemand böse möchte
und hinterlistig ist und rumtrickst was
die Drehbuchautoren über die
Gesellschaft denken
auch gerade gesagt also ist es das Geld
wert was wir dort investieren und da
glaube ich gibt es eine so große
Medienvielfalt in diesem Land das
möglicherweise ein
öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender absolut
ausreichend wäre und dann glaube ich ist
ja die Aufgabe des
öffentlich-rechtlichen Senders auch
ausgewogen zu berichten und wenn man
sich dort die Talkshows anschaut und wir
haben Jungs ja eine Umfrage von mediathe
nur auch gesehen wie berichtet wird
beispielsweise über Politiker da muss
man sagen dann fehlt diese
Ausgewogenheit vollkommen gibt diese
Auswertung von Januar 2021 bis dezember
2022 und wunder wunder Marlo 3er Chefin
auf Rates kommt in der Berichterstattung
gut weg nur gute Beiträge oder
ausgewogene Beiträge wir erinnern aber
es gab eine große Flutkatastrophe in
diesem Zeitraum und offensichtlich hat
Manu Dreyer aus sich zumindest auch das
ZDF und der ARD da so gut wie alles
richtig gemacht und das das widerspricht
den tats machen dass sie sich
beispielsweise in der Flut nach der
irgendwann noch verabschiedet hat gesagt
hat ich bin jetzt nicht mehr zu
erreichen und dann erst morgen früh
wieder widerspricht den Tatsachen Armin
Laschet ist über die Dinge die passiert
sind in der Flugzeit dann so gestolpert
dass er nicht mehr Kanzler werden konnte
und das ZDF berichtet also über Malu
Dreyer nur positiv maximal neutral in
denen heute Nachrichten das kann nicht
wahr sein da sieht man auch dass es
einen gewissen politischen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Filz gibt und den
muss man nicht finanzieren diesen Tisch
nicht unbedingt Fans werden das jetzt
gesprochen eine radikale
reformkassenstall was wäre das nur noch
ein öffentlich-rechtlicher Sender oder
brauchen wir die gar nicht mehr oder
zumindest die Gebühren nicht mehr
privatisieren was könnte man tun also
grundsätzlich lassen wir es doch die
Bürger entscheiden wenn ich das gerne
abonnieren möchte dann sage ich dafür
und wenn nicht dann gibt's das nicht ich
meine müssen sie genauso sich in der
Marktwirtschaft zu Recht finden wie alle
anderen sie haben sie haben eine Hoheit
und ist schon seit Jahren wird in das
Geld hinten reingesteckt aber das was
sie berichten spiegelt nicht mehr das
wirklich wieder was der Bürger ist also
sie sind vollkommen Fans ähnlich wie im
Bundestag und ich sehe da sehr viele par
stellen und linkes Auge und grünes Auge
blinkt auch da sehe ich viele Parallelen
also lassen wir doch die Bürger
entscheiden die sollten sowieso viel
mehr Entscheidungsrecht haben und dann
werden wir da mal sehen wie viel sie
sich noch ein konsolenpension leisten
können ich denke das wird dann rapide
herabgesetzt an diese Frage des
Sprechens des Gender sprechen also wir
erleben jetzt das Politiker
beispielsweise Bürgerinnen und Bürger
sagen und aber in den sozialen Medien
das ZDF selbst immer ein gender Stern
dazu fügt beispielsweise also da werden
Dinge auch noch falsch wirklich falsch
berichtet und sie haben es ja vollkommen
richtig gesagt so spricht die große
Mehrheit spricht nicht so und wenn die
große mehr aber so sprechen soll dann
muss man einfach den Bürger entscheiden
lassen sondern wir stellen das ab wir
wollen nicht so Bescheid werden auch
nicht so erzogen werden verdient euer
Geld am besten selbst und dann wird man
sehen ähm wie wir dann in den
Nachrichten angesprochen werden ob als
BürgerInnen oder als Bürger einfach nur
und für sie müsste dann nur noch der
Tatort bleiben ist das alles was sie
wollen das nicht also ich nehme sie eine
Reformhaus ich als Konsument ist die
große Gefahr ist dass das
öffentlich-rechtliche Fernsehen gerade
Riesenfehler macht und zwar den Fehler
macht nicht zu sehen dass hier eine
unglaublich teure zwangssubventionierte
Institution mitten im Fokus einer
grundsätzlich kritisch bestimmten
bestimmten Öffentlichkeit steht es geht
ja nicht nur um das Fernsehen um die
Schulen es geht um die öffentlichen
Toiletten es geht um die Bahn es geht um
den um die Flughäfen etc und
von eine unterschwellige Empörung macht
sich breit und immer breit und zwar auch
weit außerhalb der AFD oder der Linken
ja und das die ARD und das ZDF also die
öffentlich rechtlichen Sender stehen
gewissermaßen die werden den Prügel
Knaben abgeben es wird so weit kommen
und und die lassen es auch soweit kommen
tombur oder der Chef der der das DDR hat
ja im letzten Jahr im Prinzip schon mal
einen Ansatz gemacht wo aber klar
abzusehen dass sie jetzt sechs Monate
her oder so das versandet sie das ist
eine Institution die sich so stark und
fest fühlt wie die SED-Spitze 1989 waren
bei den Reformen was schlagen Sie also
vor
unbedingt Schritte brutale Schritte die
irgendein Prozess muss eingeleitet
werden von Trial and Error man wird nie
kein Mensch keine Partei wird mit einem
Wurf jetzt den idealen
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk der
Zukunft haben wir haben 60 Jahre Stau
praktisch in dem ganzen oder 30 Jahre
auf jeden Fall Stau in dem drin
Zusammenlegung ARD ZDF einfach manches
muss man erst einmal kaputt schlagen
damit wieder was neues zusammenwachsen
kann ich würde es wirklich nicht sagen
nur noch Tatort ja aber wir müssen sehen
muss ein öffentlich rechtlich bezahlte
Rundfunk den den ganzen Trend zum Trash
TV mitgehen ich habe übrigens immer was
vergessen achte sich sehr gerne ja diese
deutsche französische gut das hatten
gewissen hinterlegt werden Niveau und so
also da bin ich jetzt schon noch mehr
als beim Tatort engagiert aber der der
ganze Trash TV muss muss die Konkurrenz
mit den privaten so laufen ähm obwohl
man einseitig finanzierte diese Fragen
müssen die nur gestellt werden sondern
die müssen einfach mal auch man muss
einfach mal den gordischen Knoten wir
sind an einem Punkt wo der KN dürfen
nicht mehr nicht mehr
befreit oder geöffnet werden kann
sondern wer wirklich durchgeschlagen
werden muss was bedeutet das ja bloß
dann auch für Sport und Unterhaltung
muss es so etwas gar nicht geben
Gebühren finanziert braucht man wirklich
nur noch einen Sender wie stehen sie
sich
wozu denn Sport ich bin sehr
begeisterter oder war es mit ein
bisschen noch Fußballfan heute spielt
Bayern München das läuft auf Amazon
Prime glaube ich wenn ich recht
informiert bin gut das kann man machen
das kann man dann zahlen 90 € im Jahr
ich mache übrigens keine Werbung keine
Sorge aber nein nein es ist völlig
unsinnig und unnötig das Unterhaltung
mit finanziert wird weil man muss das
nicht man darf das nicht vergessen wenn
man die Gebühren nicht zahlt folgt
Zwangsgeld und zwangsaft das heißt die
fängnis es gab Leute die schon im
Gefängnis waren deswegen weil sie nicht
in aller Freundschaft und Tatort mit
finanzieren wollten und das muss man
sich doch wirklich mal auf der Zunge
zergehen lassen deswegen nein weg damit
zerschlagen
in unserem Land frei die Kinder
missbraucht haben da sind wir schon
gleich bei ihrem Thema ganz wichtiges
Thema über das wir heute Abend auch
sprechen wollen noch einmal zurück auch
Jan zu diesem zahlen also gleichzeitig
will viele sind sie hier am Tisch
eigentlich sagen also muss ich endlich
was tun gleichzeitig schaut man sich an
über 400.000 Euro kriegt man dann quasi
fürs nichts tun für die Verabschiedung
aus dem Job 9000 9000 € Rente dafür kann
man nur träumen was ist das auch für ein
Signal
veröffentlich sind ganz ganz viele Dinge
auseinandergelaufen und ähm das Problem
was man das sie dort sehen ist das eine
ganz ganz enge Verknüpfung gibt zwischen
dem Journalismus und dem Politikern die
einen also Journalisten sollen in
gewisser Weise kam ich möchte nicht
sagen überwachen aber immer wieder
überprüfen ist das was du tust
eigentlich richtig genau umgekehrt sehen
wir es ja dass in diesen Rundfunkgeräten
ganz ganz viele Politiker sitzen die
umgekehrt also die Journalisten
überwachen überprüfen sollen und das
kann ja nicht funktionieren also wenn
man sich gegenseitig kontrollieren soll
gibt es automatisch ein System von
Abhängigkeiten und das ist noch nie
funktioniert und das genau sehen wir
jetzt halt auch dort und vielleicht noch
ein Punkt um das einmal nur klar zu
machen wir sind ja Journalisten und
natürlich ist Jobabbau für jeden den
erfährt eine ganz ganz blöde Sache und
das glaube ich sei einmal dahin gesagt
auch weil es viele tolle Kollegen auch
bei den öffentlichen rechtlichen gibt
aber was mir immer wieder auffällt ist
wenn wir zu Pressekonferenzen gehen
beispielsweise oder zu anderen
Veranstaltungen dann sehe ich immer ganz
ganz viele verschiedene Mikrofone
öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunkanstalt
und da ist ja schon die Frage warum geht
da nicht eine Person hin und bedient die
restlichen Rundfunkanstalten mit warum
muss der Radio Bremen der seine Rundfunk
der Bayerische Rundfunk der Hessische
Rundfunk und im Zweifel noch der
Norddeutsche Rundfunk eigentlich jeweils
eine Person hinschicken das kann eine
Person machen einfach Mikro hin eine
Kamera im Zweifel noch aufstellen und
dann bedient man mit einer einzigen
persona mit zweien die ganze ganze
Landschaft dafür braucht man nicht zehn
zwölf 14 18 Leute